let's jump to this story we got this
tweet that alex has mentioned marjorie
taylor green she said these foolish
cowards want the government to take away
guns and the rights of parents to defend
their children in schools you have to be
an idiot to think gun control will
create a utopian society where criminals
disarm themselves and obey the law let's
play this and see exactly what happened
children we are helping kids
no i'm not
getting fired
you're helping very cowardice
i love marjorie
you're the one running away
like it's funny this guy is like he's
not good at what you do no they're
trying to do that real quick they're
copying my bit they after i get all this
media they're like oh let's go hang out
where they and i'm i'm not the first
person to do this so i don't care you're
allowed to i like the copycats my point
being is you're right he's not doing
good he doesn't have the selfie stick he
doesn't have the hutzpah as they say he
doesn't have and he doesn't have he
doesn't know what he's talking about
yeah he's not even he's not even
passionate take away your guns
i want to live in a country where kids
don't get shot he just keeps saying the
same thing over again like bro nobody
wants to live in a country or kids are
getting shot and like we're actively
trying to stop this but all you do is
you're like we should have a gun-free
zone and it's like then what do we do
when the kids get shot call the guys
with guns and tell them to come that's
insane dude yeah when they take away the
guns the only people who have the guns
are the cops military and criminals so i
mean
it's like we want to create a place
where there's no guns what happens if
someone walks past that sign you better
call the guy with a gun why don't we
have a guy with a gun there no no it's a
gun-free zone okay you know what dude
it's like the energy thing they're like
carbon emissions are bad we have nuclear
power no nuclear you can't do why
you know it's bad why is it bad well you
know whatever
okay okay well you're not they're not
offering solutions they're offering
problems and you know why probably
because when they make more problems
they can vote to say the ones who are
going to solve the problems and they
just make more problems yeah i think you
get a really strong point i mean uh
they they say when i get when i walk and
i go through dc there's this weird
energy of just red tape like they want
more crap to complain about or to
legendary they need it yeah that's why
they don't want to let racism go and
they never want a solution to your point
they never want a solution because they
can always
create the fear and create the and i
mean the reality is one of the things
we've done in oklahoma we're keeping
pushing for other schools to do this put
a big sign out in front of the school
that says some staff here are armed
and if you enter here to hurt kids they
will use all forces necessary to take
you out there you go hey you don't know
who it is you don't know where it is but
guess what you're not going to come into
our schools and attack our kids you're
not going to do it and you know or you
can have the opposite which is what
we've seen other places around the
country basically put up a big sign that
goes don't worry there is no one here
with a gun
and we've got the most precious asset
possible our kids and don't worry
there's no gun by the way that's the
craziest thing to me
it's absurd so have you seen the veritas
thing where they would go door to door
and they were like
you know do you favor gun control and
they're like yes like would you be
willing to put up a sign in your yard
saying proud gun freedom and they're
like no
and then he was like why not and they
were like because we'd be inviting
criminals and they were like
are you saying you think you need a gun
to defend yourself and they're like uh
uh
it's just anti-comm it's just common
sense it's not it's not anything you
know it's not rocket science it's just
common sense what is this you know alex
i did notice earlier
i was i was just going to ask alex if
you know a water drop got on you and
then you kind of like got shaken and
then a gremlin troll came out and that
was that guy who was there yeah
i'm sorry
my point is i saw alex over there
with this uh you know kind of doing the
selfie routine earlier look at the angle
there is he even getting them that's
what i'm saying you got to go high and
everybody's so short you have to have
the angle you got to get and you got to
kind of make your face look better
no i i mean you know when it comes to uh
confronting these politicians if you're
not passionate about this guy it's just
it's just kind of a dud and i was giving
marjorie some some pointers i think that
you have to not engage a little bit
maybe engage in because you want to act
like you're on the same level but that's
what i talked about when i first went to
like city council meetings and i would
speak seriously they wouldn't and i
think you should engage well that's what
i'm saying but my point is what i want
to do when i troll them is i want them
to engage so you want to engage with
what the person doesn't want you to say
does that make sense like you like as a
politician you want to engage with him
well you want to shut him down i would
always start with like a softball
question i'm like hey how's your day
going hey you got you know you're a
really great person and then they let
their guard down and then i would hit
them with a
legendary stuff you know he went
confronted larry silverstein
so i mean that is one of the amazing
rockefeller right you got rockefeller
rod childs big new brzezinski henry
kissinger a bunch of times
and luke luke's been to epstein island
tony blair bill clinton al gore we made
al gore cancel his book tour i think he
missed that one
wow wow you guys think it's a big deal a
little dan crenshaw five foot three like
you're right
that's nothing compared to what luke's
done so i'm gonna kiss your butt a
little bit normally when i say that
luke's ben epstein island he corrects it
really quick but this time i'm tired
i'm tired of this
well he also went to zorro ranch in new
mexico and uh did you go to the big owl
statue
the cremation of ceremonies
the troll stuff i think the reason it
works is because none of these people
actually know how to deal with it
and if it were me look i understand like
you're on your way somewhere and so like
marjorie has clearly like got something
to do but for me i actually would just
stop and be like what's up yeah i agree
i think you do need to engage him a
little bit but my point being is uh you
gotta be kind of smart and cunning yeah
i'd let him talk and then i'd be like
you want me to answer and then i'll try
to answer and if they're just playing a
troll game i just be calm about it and
be like
and then just be like i'll answer you
know whatever it asks me a question i
think the issue is that especially for
people like crenshaw the only thing he
could say was well you hate veterans
because he didn't have anything to say
he didn't have an argument to make
anybody who's arguing that the the wars
in the middle east were a mistake is
right it's they are correct and like the
overall majority of this country agree
with that so how do you defend being in
favor of war today when most people are
like we don't want to be involved in
this garbage anymore tim how obvious is
it how obvious was the pivot from
afghanistan to the ukraine it was like
seamless all of a sudden we went from
we're out of afghanistan now we're just
spending billions and billions and
billions of dollars to the you know
proxy war in ukraine killing russians
from you know our money
they have to continue to keep these wars
going and it's just so blatantly obvious
but sadly everybody is asleep they have
no idea what's really happening
how do you make them up i don't know but
you yell at people and call them big
booty yeah i mean sometimes well that's
the other thing is too when you're
taking a nap and somebody shakes you and
wakes you from the nap then you're like
mad at the person for waking you up so
it's really hard i think with me and
this is me talking personally when i
tried to wake people up and i'm sure
luke might have had the same thing it's
kind of hard people don't want to know
you know that information because it's
deep you have to put a lot of time into
it and it's kind of negative vibrational
energy it puts you in this bad head
space but for me what's been effective
in making people question the reality is
comedy and you said earlier that they
don't have solutions well i think they
do it's a hegelian dialectic where they
do have solutions called problem
reaction solution but the solution that
we have that we want and what they want
is so different and they have a saying
is you know the ends justify the means
so it's like we need to we need to kind
of do the same thing kind of like the
sololinsky's rules for radicals and in
that one of the things is whatever you
do wrong or whatever you get accused of
accuse the accuser of the same thing and
that's what we have to do is we kind of
have to use their rules against them and
create the solution that we want where
kids you know are not being
indoctrinated and then we kind of use
the hegelian dialectic against the new
world order well for me personally just
being happy healthy and prosperous is an
act of resistance in our modern day
society and if you could be an example
of that and if you could lead by example
that's one of the biggest things you
could do open the door you can't push
people through because the more you do
the more you're going to have a negative
effect with it and i i think leading
with solutions celebrating our victories
and just
admitting yes we're living in very
tumultuous crazy times but but these
times also provide us an opportunity to
challenge ourselves and make us the best
version of ourselves that we could
create right now with this huge uphill
battle that seems impossible but in that
in that journey we're going to learn and
have a lot of incredible learning
lessons that are going to stay with us
for the rest of our lives
did we learn from the pandemic no i know
that's brilliant a lot of people have a
lot of people have learned from 911 they
they learn from iraq
and again it's a balance yin and yang
there's negative forces there's positive
forces in this world which one are you
going to give your energy towards right
so so i think it's it's a choice that we
all make constantly and i think if we
focus on helping people not being
victims because there's a lot of victims
and if we could prevent people from
being victims of the next psy up of the
next mind control of the next uh
scam that's going to be hitting people
that's a huge victory in itself and it's
up to the person themselves to decide if
they're going to be a victim or if
they're going to be thriving in this
world it's your choice many people are
doing like survival training
i am and and there's a huge interest in
it and there's been there's been a lot
of classes that have been selling out
all over the country with individuals
doing these types of trainings because
one it's fun and and two it's great to
have a skill that you could actually
offer to a community that would be
wonderful even if if ish hits the fan
you will be prepared no matter what
that's why i started apocalypse survival
uh part of my program on we are
change.org it's funny that you said ish
hits the fan yeah so it just sounded
like you said ish hitched the fan you
sound like you said
[ __ ]
family i still said it in a family
friendly way thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there